thanks to blinkist for helping support
this episode
must animate more clones
wait is this even gonna work
[Music]
this episode was made possible by
generous supporters on patreon
hey crazies let's have some fun and
apply what we know about electrodynamics
to the nervous system
brains it's a field of study called
electrophysiology
which mainly covers nerves but is also
concerned with things like
muscles in the heart because you know
that nervous system thing is all over
the place
electrophysiology shares some important
history with electromagnetism and
physics
to the timeline prior to the late 18th
century
models for mechanisms underlying the
brain and movement
involve various types of fluids and
spirits
in ancient greece fluidy spirity stuff
was referred to as
pneuma but that word has since become a
prefix for other words
like pneumatic and pneumonia which are
related to gases and pressure
in 1646 rene descartes argued that the
neuromuscular system was essentially a
hydraulic system
where animal spirits flowed from parts
of the brain
into the muscles but by the 1790s
we started to figure out what was really
going on in 1786
luigi galvani entered the field of
physiology
it's a me luigi no not that luigi
unbelievable in 1786
galvani did a few experiments with
lightning rods and frog legs
they were dead frog legs there was no
animal cruelty going on here okay
anyway he hooked up a lightning rod to
some dead frog legs
and they twitched in response to
electric shocks
galvani called this behavior animal
electricity when he finally published it
in 1791
in an essay called commentary on the
effect of electricity
on muscular motion you know a typical
boring science title
but descriptive eventually galvani
discovered the lightning rod
wasn't actually necessary he could make
the dead frog legs twitch
simply by touching them with a
combination of two metals
called a bi-metal galvani used this fact
to argue that animal electricity was
actually intrinsic to the frog itself
and as we'll see soon he wasn't
completely wrong
but a rival of galvanize named
alessandro volta argued that
volta the volta the volta we named the
volt after
yep that's the one volta suggested that
animal electricity wasn't intrinsic to
the frog
but came from the bi-metal somehow and
as it turns out
volta was right the bi-metal is capable
of producing its own electricity
the two metals reacted with the
electrochemical fluids in the dead frog
leg
forming a primitive voltaic cell huh
a battery the bi-metal turned the frog
legs into a battery
really yes really volta
literally discovered electrochemistry
and invented the precursor to the
battery
just to prove galvani wrong it's crazy
where an argument will take you
anyway back to the timeline voltaic
cells
set the stage for experimental
physicists like orsted
ampere and faraday to develop
electromagnetism in the 19th century
so the next time you charge your phone
don't forget about the frog
galvani stopped his research after
napoleon invaded italy in 1796
but the idea of reanimating life with
electricity
captivated early 19th century society
it was the inspiration for mary
shelley's frankenstein in 1818
so is this gonna work nope definitely
not
frankenstein is just a story this is not
how clones are made
okay then
luigi galvani was probably stimulating
the frog's sciatic nerve
a nerve is a biological cable consisting
of a bundle of fibers called axons
um what's an axon the part of a typical
neuron that carries electrical impulses
when it comes to the brain the neuron is
usually the star of the show
your brain contains about a hundred
billion of them
isn't that also the number of stars in
the milky way galaxy
yeah it's the right order of magnitude
but why are you asking
didn't you say it was the star of the
show yes as a metaphor
this video is about brain stuff so
what's a neuron
a simple model of a neuron has three
parts the main cell body
dendrites which receive signals and
axons
which send signals and can sometimes
span an entire limb
one of the things that makes neurons
special is their ability to generate
and transmit electrical pulses over
relatively long distances
and they do that reliably and fast
enough to respond to the environment
so galvani was on the right track kind
of
but we've come a long way in our
understanding of electrodynamics since
then
back to the timeline we'd have to wait
until the 20th century
before scientists really pinned down the
biophysics of this electrical axon thing
in 1906 ramon received the nobel prize
for his pioneering work on the general
structure and function of the neuron
but it wasn't until 1952 that alan
hodgkin
and andrew huxley teamed up to discover
the biophysical mechanism for electrical
pulses and neurons
hodgkin and huxley were both
biophysicists so they decided to tackle
the problem
they did their experiments on the squid
giant axon
a giant squid axon like 20 000 leagues
under the sea kind of giant squid
no no not a giant squid axon a squid
giant axon
the axon was giant not the squid
that made it more accessible and easier
to work with i mean who wants to work
with a tiny human neuron am i right
anyway if you look up the hodgkin-huxley
model
you'll probably see differential
equations that look like this
of course equations don't exude
intuition so let's try to make a visual
instead
think of a neuron like a leaky bag of
charged liquid
it's mostly water but it has ions like
potassium sodium and chlorine dissolved
in it
a neuron like all cells has a
two-layered cell membrane
when it's not doing anything the neuron
maintains a potential difference
a voltage across the membrane how does
it do that
ion pumps ion pumps run on chemical
energy known in the bio world
as atp this is a major reason our brains
consume
20 of the energy we eat
outside the cell there's a higher
concentration of positive ions like
sodium
inside the cell there's a higher
concentration of positive ions like
potassium
negative ions like chlorine are spread
out all over the place
the ion pumps are specialized protein
structures
embedded in the cell membrane that pump
specific ions
against the concentration gradient and
against the electric potential
if necessary fight the gradient
i know this is all sounding very
biological but it's just electrodynamics
it's just circuit stuff ion pumps use
energy to move electric charges around
that's what batteries and other voltage
sources do
in the hodgkin-huxley model ion pumps
are like batteries
remember how the cell membrane has two
layers well that's just a capacitor
the ion pumps built up electric charge
on either side
creating a voltage in the hodgkin-huxley
model
the cell membrane is a capacitor ion
pumps are not the only devices that span
the cell membrane though
there are also ion channels when these
channels are open
ions can and will try to balance their
concentration
ions are just electric charges and when
charges flow
we call that an electric current it's
positive charge too
so the idea of conventional current
isn't even a lie this time
but what really matters here is what the
ion channels represent
in the circuit the ions don't flow
through the channels all the time
and they flow at different rates at
different times that's a lot like a
variable resistor
one controlled by some kind of timer in
the hodgkin-huxley model
ion channels are variable resistors
they control the electric current by
ohm's law just like any other resistor
each ion channel is selective though
it'll only allow a specific type of ion
to pass through
sodium channels only let through sodium
ions
potassium channels only let through
potassium ions
so how are they variable because they're
voltage gated
there are actually several different
ways an ion channel could be gated
chemically gated channels on cells that
neurons talk to
mechanically gated channels that are
sensitive to pressure or stretch
and even light gated channels in the eye
but the ones in the axon
are voltage-gated how open they are
depends on the voltage across the cell
membrane
and that voltage can change with time in
fact it will change
with time as long as that neuron is
trying to talk to other cells
these voltage-gated ion channels are
vital for getting a signal to the end of
the axon
the signal kind of rolls its way down
the chain
hodgkin and huxley modeled this process
as a simple electric circuit
the cell membrane is a capacitor the ion
pumps are rechargeable batteries
and the ion channels are variable
resistors
let's take a look at the voltage across
the cell membrane aka the capacitor
as the nerve tries to send a signal
there are four stages
resting depolarization repolarization
and hyperpolarization jargon alert
jargon alert
i've been driving bio words this entire
video now is the time you get on my case
okay okay i suppose technically the
membrane is polarized as long as there's
a voltage across it
which as you can see is true almost the
entire time
it blows right past zero twice
but we have to tell these stages apart
so it helps to think of polarization
as just the resting state the membrane
is stable
depolarization is when the voltage rises
towards zero
but overshoots repolarization is when
the voltage rebounds and drops toward
the resting state
hyperpolarization is when that
overshoots
don't get too hung up on the names
wasn't this supposed to be about
circuits
oh yeah yeah right we were talking about
the hodgkin-huxley model
but i think this will make the most
sense if we look at everything together
let's sync up all three visuals first
the voltage-gated sodium channels
are triggered to open allowing a rapid
flow of sodium ions
into the cell the voltage across the
membrane goes from negative 70
millivolts
up to around positive 30 millivolts but
remember they're on a timer
so after the initial spike the sodium
channels close
when those close the potassium channels
open
rapidly sending potassium ions out of
the cell
the voltage across the membrane drops
back down toward the resting state
finally after an overshoot the potassium
channels close
and the membrane settles back into the
resting state
it does this by leaking a little and if
necessary
by turning on the ion pumps in short
the channels balance the ion
concentration and the pumps unbalance
them again
the hodgkin-huxley circuit successfully
models this entire mechanism
but only for a little patch of the cell
membrane
this patch only has a few things one
sodium potassium pump
one potassium channel one sodium channel
and whatever other miscellaneous devices
are around
the signal process starts locally
usually around where the cell body and
the axon meet
it then spreads as a chain reaction from
one patch of the membrane to the next
local regions depolarize their neighbors
sending a pulse down the axon
and this happens fast fast fast
the entire spiking process starts and
finishes in about a thousandth of a
second
but how fast does the signal take to get
down the axon
good question it actually depends
it varies a lot depending on the type of
neuron and the animal species
but at top speed we're looking at about
224 miles per hour
or a hundred meters per second that's
the length of an entire football field
including the end zones in a single
second
compared to how fast signals travel
through wires though this is
actually pretty slow oh no does that
give robots the advantage
anyway so it took us a while to figure
out neurons
the real work began with luigi galvani
and dead frog legs
but culminated with alan hodgkin and
andrew huxley in their circuit model
a neuron is like a simple electric
circuit or at least a chain of simple
circuits
it's made of capacitors batteries and
resistors that obey ohm's law
components that create a pulsing voltage
all just to tell other cells what to do
let's just hang here for a bit and
take it all in
so got any questions about this analogy
please ask in the comments
thanks for liking and sharing this video
don't forget to subscribe if you'd like
to keep up with us
and until next time remember it's okay
to be a little crazy
i'd like to thank this video sponsor
blinkist
have you ever been in one of those
social situations where everyone's
talking about some popular nonfiction
book but you haven't read it
i mean who has time to read a book in
this fast-paced world we live in anyway
i've got more important things to do
well blinkist can solve your problem
it's an app you can get on your phone or
tablet that phone doesn't even have a
sim card
it's fine i use an old phone for
podcasts and stuff okay
anyway blinkist takes the best insights
from over
3 000 non-fiction books and condenses
them into about 15 minutes
you can read the summaries yourself or
even listen to someone else read them to
you
they've got books all over the spectrum
like born a crime by trevor noah
or a brief history of time by stephen
hawking all condensed into about 15
minutes
they've even started offering member
discounts on full-length audiobooks if
you're into that sort of thing
the first hundred people who go to
blinkist.com
science asylum can get unlimited access
for a whole week to try it out for free
if you don't like it you can cancel
anytime during that week
but if you decide to keep it you'll also
get 25
off the full membership price at the end
of the one week trial
go to blinkist.comscienceasylum or click
the link in the description below to get
started
the featured comment comes from derek
cochran who said
relativity is definitely not a cinch to
understand
i see what you did there cinch as in
hyperbolic sign
good one anyway thanks for watching